je peux savoir ce que tu fais sur mon
ordinateur je regarde un extrait de 1789
les amants de la bastille c'est une
sorte d'uchronie où des gens veulent
renverser le pouvoir et pour ça il faut
qu'il prenne un bâtiment super important
qui s'appelle la bastille va savoir
pourquoi pour eux c'est la chose à faire
et à partir de là ils font la révolution
française
ouais je sais c'est complètement
surréaliste
d'ailleurs on est à quel juan nos jours
charles xiii
ok on a du retard à rattraper
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouvel
épisode de chroniques de profs troisième
du nom nous allons revenir sur la
révolution française ce que vous savez
ce que vous pensez savoir est ce que
vous ignorez comme cette jeune fille qui
a amélioré doute détail taveneau
remarques à faire avant de commencer ils
sont pas tuer le roi ils n'ont pas tué
le roi si ils l'ont fait mais tout ça
fait partie d'un processus complexe que
nous allons expliquer ensemble et tout
d'abord pour en revenir à ce que tu me
disais avant le générique
si je te dis révolution française qu'est
ce que cette époque barnard y faire
d'effort prise de la bastille très bien
et bien sache que cet événement dont
tout le monde se rappelle n'est pas très
important mais pourtant on en a fait une
comédie musicale
on a d'abord dit que prendra la bastille
a servi à libérer les prisonniers
honteusement enfermée là mais ils
n'étaient que 7 à l'époque il était
tellement peu nombreux que les
révolutionnaires sont allés à inventer
un prisonnier supplémentaires on a aussi
considéré que la prise de la bastille
était un symbole c'était la destruction
du pouvoir arbitraire du roi la fin de
son pouvoir d'enfermer les innocents par
sa seule volonté
un acte de rébellion du peuple souverain
contre le despotisme son rôle oui bah a
cool c'était quoi alors il y avait de la
poudre dans la bastille les émeutiers
avaient choqué des armes dans les
casernes des environs mais il n'avait
pas de poudre lors ils sont allés servir
là où il y en avait point ils ont voulu
fermer parce que l'euro avait fait venir
des troupes autour de paris ce qui est
fait peur aux parisiens la révolution
avait déjà commencé avant le 14 juillet
sur le plan politique et a continué bien
après c'est donc tout bon là-bas style
on est venu on l'a vu on en parlera plus
oui mais c'est quand même devenu un
symbole pour la france je vu que c'était
devenu la journée nationale et mène ça
c'est faux le 14 juillet ne commémore
pas la prise de la bastille du 14
juillet 1789 mais la fête de la
fédération du 14 juillet 1790 au lieu de
célébrer un événement violent et sans
grand intérêt sur le plan politique on
commémore une fête célébrant l'unité de
la nation ce qui a un peu plus de sens
même si tout le monde a oublié comme
dans vingt ans aux origines de cette
révolution partie 1
les causes eh bien c'est la crise mon
bon monsieur pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord l'idée d'un roi concentrant tous
les pouvoirs commence à être montré du
doigt notamment par les philosophes des
lumières qui sont entendus par une
partie de la population pendant les
campagnes mais dans la bourgeoisie des
villes avant les lumières j'y vais
on découpe la tête il a droit
après des lumières givet qu'on lui coupe
la dette à fives le despotisme éclairé
la france traverse également une crise
économique que les ministres successifs
n'arrive pas à régler et c'est justement
pour discuter d'une réforme fiscale qui
ne passe pas que le roi décide
finalement de convoquer les états
généraux une sorte d'assemblée
réunissant les trois ordres
à notre gauche nous avons la noblesse
ordres anciens et prestigieux dans
lequel on ne rentre que si on a reçu une
invitation et qui peut se payer un
appart en plein centre de paris sans
même payer d'impôts à notre droite le
clergé indispensable pour le salut de
vos amis vous prélève des fortunes mais
il vous le rend bien et au milieu barque
tout le reste
le tir est un des états généraux se
réunissent donc après que les différents
villages des corps de métiers et rédiger
des cahiers de doléances dans lesquelles
ils expriment toute leur revendication
chère louis saez
comme j'ai été sage cette année je
voudrais pouvoir manger à ma faim tous
les jours je voudrais aussi ne plus être
écrasé sous une charge d'impôt aberrante
j'aimerais que tu arrêtes d'enfermer des
gens sans même qu'il soit jugé que la
paix règne dans le monde et que tous les
citoyens soient libres et heureux
c'est beau nous arrivons maintenant aux
événements les états généraux prennent
rapidement une tournure que n'avait pas
prévu les 16
en effet les trois ordres étaient
séparés pour délibérer ce qui ne
convient pas aux tirs états qui décident
d'inviter la noblesse et le clergé à
nous rejoindre ce que certains acceptent
en voyant qu'il ya plus d'ambiance chez
le tiers état ensuite il décide de
rédiger une constitution pour la france
et ça c'est une révolution
nous sommes le 17 juin 1789 et c'est le
début de la fin pour louis saez on
entend souvent parler du serment du jeu
de paume rendu célèbre par un tableau de
david
en fait en voyant que les députés se met
à faire tout sauf ce qui était prévu
louis saha dans un plan machiavélique il
fait fermer la salle dans laquelle se
réunissaient les députés g demi un
cadenas sur la porte la révolution et
philippe
du coup les députés se réunissent dans
la première salle qui trouve le court de
tennis local et jurent qu'ils resteront
ensemble jusqu'au bout
heureusement quand je pars la crapette
dans cette salle ça aura témoin en place
dans la nuit du 4 au 5 août les députés
qui sont maintenant des membres des
trois ans organise une grande soirée
dans la classe c'est à celui qui
piétinera le plus ces institutions dans
lesquelles il a grandi je parle bien sûr
de l'abolition des privilèges un grand
moment d'histoire de france où les
membres de la noblesse et du clergé
s'expriment tour à tour pour mettre fin
à leurs privilèges
cependant l'euphorie il se met à rejeter
leurs privilèges à tort et à travers si
bien que le lendemain certains essayent
de revenir sur leur décision
malheureusement pour eux heureusement
pour nous ça ne passe pas ai-je aboli
les banalités et jolie le droit de
cuissage avec la mise à 2 mignot rang le
lendemain matin
mais que font ces paysans dans mes bras
en chasse vous avez aboli les droits
seniors ne veulent pas bricoler comme ça
ou encore savoir y en a qui se sont
réveillés sans culotte par la suite les
députés continuent de faire leur travail
de député non leur vrai travail il
rédige la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen un préambule à la
constitution inspirée du human rights
anglais ou de la déclaration
d'indépendance américaine rendue célèbre
par un grand acteur américain nicholas
cage raconte la suite nom de dieu bon
après ça il rédige la constitution et
comme elle s'appelle la constitution de
1791 je vous laisse calculer combien de
temps elle met à être finalisés entre
temps le roi a tenté de s'éclipser en
vain
lors de la fuite de varennes le vergeur
1791 louis saez quitte paris où il était
sous bonne garde avec sa famille afin de
rejoindre l'est de la france se trouve
des troupes prêtes à organiser une
contre révolution
malheureusement pour lui certains des
partisans de louis saez qui sont
disséminés le long du trajet sont pour
le moins incompétent fille le voyage
prend du retard
à paris la fayette qui avait la garde du
roy envoie des hommes à ses recherches
et fait croire au peuple que le roi
était enlevé afin de ne pas diffuser le
vrai message que louis saez voulait
faire passer aux français et que vous
pouvez retrouver en cliquant sur ce lien
en chemin la compagnie reconnue par
plusieurs personnes et c'est à varennes
qui sont finalement arrêtés puis ramenée
à paris sous les huées de la foule
la fille du roi aurait pu être
catastrophique pour la république si
elle avait eu l'effet escompté mais au
final elles contribuent à répandre
l'idée qu'on pourrait se passer d'un roi
pour gouverner par la suite certaines
nations voit d'un mauvais oeil ce qui se
passe en france la monarchie étant
profondément ancrée en europe à partir
de 1792 la france est donc en guerre
contre le saint empire germanique le
royaume anglo corse le royaume de
grande-bretagne au royaume de prusse le
royaume de naples le royaume de sicile
au royaume de sardaigne l'emprise russe
le royaume du portugal les
provinces-unies le grand duché de
toscane du show mode andy sheppard la
république de venise au rallye de suède
le royaume d'espagne l'empiré ottoman un
certain réalisme de français comme les
vendeurs et les choix et les ont
déshabillées dans tout ça bien sûr
répond dans leur or la norvège deservant
d une île hockey et la suite la france
parvient tout de même à s'en sortir et
gagne même quelques territoires lors du
traité damien 2802 pour revenir à la
révolution l'idée de la république suit
son cours à partir de la fille de
varenne
d'autant que l'europe à son temps à
opposer son droit de veto aux
propositions de lois de l'assemblée
dans le soupçonne de sa vie aux
monarchies et demi afin de reprendre le
poids en france la monarchie est donc
suspendue le 10 août 1792 et la
république ça progressivement en france
à partir de septembre
c'est aussi à cette période qu'on
commence à utiliser le calendrier
républicain qui restent en france jusque
1806 il reprend des noms liés à la
nature comme florea germinal viande
halal une minute s'il vous plaît c'est
qui ça je suis va sans culotte c'est
avant que vous me sortez vos blagues
paillardes à 2 assignats je tiens à
préciser qu'on m'appelle comme ça parce
que je ne porte pas ce genre d'atours
communément appelée la culotte pour la
simple raison que c'est totalement has
been
je suis surtout un révolutionnaire
militant et engagé
savoir ce que vous pensez faire de ce
type là parce que c'est très bien
d'avoir fondé une révolution mais il
faudrait prendre une décision on met à
la retraite rôle exécute la retraite on
condamne à mort c'est un symbole de
l'ancien régime qui doit disparaître
pour que la république s'installe et
c'est un être humain
grâce à cette appli de mise en scène
vous avez un aperçu des débats qui ont
agité l'assemblée lors du procès de
louis saez et à une petite majorité le
verdict et la mort de louis saez qui est
exécuté le 21 janvier 1793 la
constitution de 1791 des plus valables
puisqu'elle correspondait à une
monarchie constitutionnelle le roi des
plus fonctionnels
on réalise donc une nouvelle
constitution la constitution de 1793 qui
déchire sa maman parce qu'elle est super
démocratique on abolit l'esclavagé
d'accord le suffrage universel
vous voulez des droits sociaux on vous
donne des droits sociaux vive la france
t'emballe pas elle n'est jamais
appliquée la guerre continue la france
est en crise on décide donc d'instaurer
un gouvernement révolutionnaire
provisoire jusqu'à ce que les choses se
calment on entre alors dans la phase la
moins glorieuse de la révolution celle
où les députés ont tellement peur des
ennemis de la république qui déclare
suspecte de plus en plus de personnes
selon des conditions parfois farfelus
c'est ce qu'on appelle la période de la
terreur une fois déclaré suspect vous
êtes conduire au tribunal
révolutionnaire qui peut soit vous
acquittez soit vous exécutez au moins
ils sont jugés équitablement à partir de
juin 1794 le seul verdict possible
exécution à et qui classe le tribunal
pour être déclaré suspect rien de plus
simple il vous suffit de ne pas avoir de
frais républicains de ne pas avoir de
cocardes tricolores de ne pas porter sur
vous votre carte civique ou d'être
dénoncé par un témoin qui peuvent être
votre voisin votre pire ennemi ou un
inconnu croisé dans la rue
vous avez donc énormément de
possibilités si vous voulez faire partie
des quelques dizaines de milliers de
personnes victimes de cette période
bref tout part en cacahuète quand les
grandes figures de l'arrivée
chanceux mais tu as accusés à leur tour
les unes les autres et lorsqu'il ne
reste que robespierre comme figures
emblématiques de la terreur il est à son
tour arrêté exécuté et la terreur prend
fin peu à peu à partir de là on entre
alors dans la phase des pères de la
révolution le directoire ont rédigé une
nouvelle constitution
la jeune république connaît encore de
nombreuses péripéties avec le coup
d'état de napoléon la restauration de la
monarchie mais ça c'est une autre
histoire
c'était plutôt intéressant merci j'aime
bien cette période 6 passes ta maman
chose mais du coup si j'ai bien suivi la
prise de la bastille montrait ralliement
populaire à la révolution qui était au
départ simplement l'oeuvre de député
c'est vachement important
oui c'est pas faux rendez-vous mois
prochain